they have a boutique within a boutique
there glass of you know white burgundy
maybe a second glass of burgundy we're
having a good time talking about watches
yada yada woof woof woof I bought four
tutors that day you have three of them
in front of us right now yeah
hey Mr Wonderful here again back with
Teddy you know we do these sessions
together to talk about what we both love
which is watches now this is a series of
New pieces that come into my collection
and they're relevant because many of
them for the first time showed up on
Shark Tank season 14. so I thought I'd
go through it with Teddy but what's
interesting here is quite a few of them
are because of Teddy I never bought
low-end entry pieces I was only a
collector of high-end investable
timepieces and he got me into some of
these brands that I never thought I
would touch including stuff like tutor
which I thought to me was Poor Man's
Rolex I have a completely different
appreciation of it now and I have four
our new tutors we'll talk about that but
also my key to all collecting and Teddy
knows this is dial
you know sure technology matters sure
caliber matters sure history matters but
if the dial doesn't speak to me I don't
buy it I don't collect it and what's so
incredible Teddy is the dials that you
found for me in these low-end entry
Brands you have some incredible ones I'm
looking at that and ordain I'm looking
at some of these tutors I mean there's
and also the use of material too you've
got some bronze you have ceramic silver
you know so you're even extending Beyond
dial I think you're also finding some
pretty eclectic uses of different case
materials that make these different
shine when you're talking about an
affordable budget because when I think
of what can brands do at an attainable
range two things are usually Bound by
the movement and they don't have that
many options unless they can produce
things vertically within their own
manufacturing process so they have to
look at cases that's a way to
differentiate and then also their dials
like you mentioned so I think those are
the two areas when you're looking at
these attainable ends but they can
separate themselves so I'll follow your
lead I mean you have some amazing sure
but let's talk about animal Dean because
I didn't even know about these makers
and by the time this was over they made
a one of a kind Mr Wonderful Red Band
red dial the dial is amazing shark tank
exclusive let's tell me about them so
annardane was founded in 2015 in
Scotland and what they're known for is
enamel dials so enameling is using
powdered glass in this just oven and
baking it the rate in which there's a
lot of failure is quite high with enamel
because you're trying to get these
Beautiful Textures and different array
of colors this one has this fire truck
red I think they call it and it's just
beautiful you know you have to put your
name on everything Mr Wonderful I did
and it says right at the bottom it's
still wonderful I think it makes it
Priceless but I must say when I put this
on my wrist I remember the day we were
shooting at Lori's on my left she always
lifts up my watches and she leaned over
and said what the hell is that really
she said that she was blown away she
said that's incredible leave a look at
that she loves my pieces but this one
was a huge hit on the set of Shark Tank
and it's two thousand dollars it's in
the two thousand dollar range nobody
asks what it costs they just kept
talking about the dial which is what I'm
all about so I felt pretty good about
that let's go somewhere else to an
extraordinary piece this is a very very
limited edition I recently became an
emirati citizen so I'm very honored I
did that for financial services that I
work in all around the world but many of
the watchmakers make special series for
the 50th anniversary of UAE United Arab
Emirates his only 50 years old this is
one of those pieces now Teddy you know
this brand let's talk it's strange
because it's almost the timing of this
is crazy because I just released a video
on my channel looking at Nevada Gretchen
so this is their chronomaster this is
their Aviator sea diver which is a
mouthful of a name but it kind of gives
the idea of what this watch is about
chronograph diving functionality
bi-directional bezel and it also has
some Aviation themes in terms of what
it's going for so it's kind of just a
hot podge of us all this craziness going
on this is a brand that was has roots
back to the early 20th century but a
gentleman that is involved in the watch
industry worked at jlc you worked at
Zenith prior and he started making all
of these new brands and bringing them
back to life he has Volcan he has
Excelsior Park but Nevada Gretchen was
the one that first caught on and this is
just their Corona Master collection why
this is also so cool talking about 38
millimeter case for yeah a
cut also one of very few made for the
UAE this is the only one in North
America and the only one in the world
with a red band I've not seen that one
yet in persons that's the arabics on the
yes very cool Also let's talk about
where this started as brand awareness
South Pole
yes this was the first watch me worn by
Navy explorers to the South Pole yeah
very high quality very wonderful let's
go
um let's pick up that Rolex right there
I'll let you explain why this Rolex is
unique so Rolex
let's be frank sometimes they don't take
the most daring risks with their designs
but you won't say but why would they I
mean they're gaining market share year
over year so I don't blame them but this
was released this year and this was
almost the spurring moment that created
this to be the year of the GMT and why
this one is special for one different
bezel that they've ever done black and
green but also
what's going on here exactly the crown
what is going on there it's like the
Lefty yeah so they're Lefty so this I
would say probably one of their more
daring releases for Rolex standards
which again is not the craziest of
standards for going outside of the box
but this is out there for them it's very
out there and became an immensely
popular watch overnight because
basically you're wearing the crown on
your left hand but it's a lefty and I
think is that your first left-handed
watch no no I've got other pieces what
do you think of wearing that as somebody
because you're right-handed correct I am
correct does it bother you no not at all
I like the uniqueness of it obviously I
like the look of it but of course I
can't wear this on television which is
why I have not yet installed it'll be
being put on next week a rubber bait
they do the best Integrations with Rolex
I don't own any of this company I just
think they do a great job and I don't
wrap them in any way other than to say I
use them because they're really really
good bands it'll end up on this piece
this will be in season 15 of shark tank
but I love it and I've worn it you know
around the house with the steel band on
it very nice but you have to like the
way that looks I do and I like the green
and black bezel I think it's sharp and I
don't know if I would I don't know if
that would annoy me or not when I would
Flex in my wrist but I've never really
given a lefty a good shot like you're
going to give a lefty a good shot it
would be this one you know paderai also
does this and I have Peter has one as
well
as well but I think for Rolex to do this
that's a breakout and I think it's very
collectible piece countless people have
called me about this pizza would you
like to sell it I just got it it's a
2022. no I don't sell any of my pieces
but that's going to be a favorite for no
question very nice while we're talking
about Rolex just a shout out for the
classic steel white face Daytona this is
the most popular watch I've ever worn on
Shark Tank in terms of reviews from
people who love the show it really pops
wardrobe loves it it's been in every
season and this year it will be
auctioned at the Phillips auction for
charity in December I anticipate the
piece is going to do very very well it
will come with the original Red Band and
all the original papers and the Box all
the charity goes to Dr Martin Solomon
initiative in Boston a doctor that has a
great legacy for training younger
doctors and I want the proceed to go
there that's great and I think watch out
for this watch the philosopher the
minute I get the link I'll be posting it
all over my social now let's talk about
Tutor
just less than a year ago sitting in
this very store this incredible iconic
location for watches here in New York
tuna Brooker this is an amazing place if
you if you this is a museum a retail
location and if you're looking for a
watch every single brand you could ever
want and price point you could want is
here so I'm doing a shout out for the
store because this is a gorgeous
location to shoot
recently Teddy was trying to talk me
into tutor and I said no no Teddy no no
no no no no no it's a pushback you
weren't about it and I said I go Rolex
you know Rolex and tutor have a
relationship obviously and he said I
want you to meet the CEO of the Americas
Adam great guy and we had lunch with
them and yeah you know Adam was pitching
me on Twitter I still I'm very very
picky I mean come on I'm a high-end
collector so I was saying look it's
great to meet you you're a wonderful guy
and Teddy's terrific and yada yada tutor
tutor still didn't buy anything
get this in this very storm well not
this store the one in the meat packing
District I was picking up a piece and
who is there
it's Adam the CEO
and he's they have a boutique within a
boutique there and so we start talking
glass of you know white burgundy maybe a
second glass of burgundy we're having a
good time talking about watches
and he starts telling me about a tutor
made out of silver you know my rule
you're not a collector of a brand or a
Mark or a Maison unless you have three
pieces that's the minimum you're just
dabbling if you have one you have to
show commitment to the brand if you're
going to be a collector that's three I
bought four tutors that day you have
three of them in front of us right now
yeah so let's talk about that so you
mentioned the silver
this came out last year so this is their
black Bay 58 yeah so 58 is known for the
39 millimeter case I own one as well uh
in the Navy version but this is talking
about differentiating with material full
silver case also they change up their uh
the alloy over some of their just metal
so they're able to have this patina in a
really nice way so even this I mean this
looks great still to this this point but
you're talking about forty four hundred
dollars for this watch very wearable Mt
movement on the inside cosc certified 70
hour power server as a metal it's not
completely inert so it takes on the
patina yes of the chemistry of your skin
over time so each piece becomes its own
personality which is so intriguing and
of all of the four that I bought
including a bronze one which isn't here
right now but this piece gets people
talking they know it's not steel they
ask me about it wherever I go and it's a
very very very beautiful looking piece
and I'm very proud to have it I mean
it's a great collectible the taupe dial
too I mean this is It's works so well
with the human case and just kind of
just seamlessly transitions over without
any effort needed so beautiful watch and
very very collectible in terms of just
being quasi-rare and getting silver sure
let's take a look at another one let's
go with the fixed Helga so I think
what's happened since the black bear was
released is it's caused some of the
other collections from 200 to be on the
back burner unfortunately it's true
this was a way to reserve some
excitement around the pelagos now the
pillow goes at the time of recording
this also they unveiled a new 39
millimeter version but this was unveiled
last year at the tail end so this
connection with the Marine National and
a limited edition so this one is really
special uh because you're getting a
titanium case but the special thing here
what they call it I call it the fixed
is because of the lugs you can see that
it's a fixed bar rather than traditional
lugs so allows you to slide through
these different NATO straps and shooter
has some great ones you have it on this
red strap I think it works
just a beautiful watch yeah it is and
it's also very collectible that was the
second let's look at one last one the
ceramic here which is stunning from
across the room very stylish very
minimalist it's quite beautiful I mean
what's really going on with Tudor is
they're going into different materials
and making it really interesting to
spread yourself across you can get bonds
you can get silver and now this ceramic
yeah and one of the most attainable
ceramic watches you're gonna find so
under five thousand dollars fully
ceramic case and watch I mean this is a
crazy marble when it comes to
positioning and price also what I like
about this watch moving on the inside is
all black kind of anthracite in terms of
its looks this is also a master
chronometer and then in addition to that
we can actually look at this thing it's
an open case back it is cool so I mean
it's it's not not bad looking it's it's
a remarkable launch you think about
ceramic just cases in general yes
there's some other ones out there but
you're usually talking about usually
double the price so you can get involved
with other brands you're getting pieces
that are completely different than each
other at very very affordable prices so
now I am training tutor I'm a collector
obviously with four pieces looking at
new opportunities I think Tudor has
really gotten aggressive in getting out
there with new ideas for collectors at
prices you can afford so it's terrific
now let's get a little off pieces like
to see let's get that crazy aventi right
there so you have to tell me a little
bit more about this brand this my first
time seeing one of these in person what
do you think
so I am more of a conservative type in
terms of the taste right so this is out
there for me but there's no question
that this case
this is sapphire case it is sapphire
pretty pretty crazy and then price on
this is you're talking about what like
14 500 okay
so first time yeah
yes it's aggressive yes it's big bold
but my goodness you want to talk about a
Shark Tank television watch
look at that and so these are young
watchmakers that are breaking out out of
Australia and I like to support an issue
of an entrepreneurship and you know I've
been talking to them about these designs
which are outlandish but not so crazy
think about Richard Mills think about
what's going on sure I mean there's all
kinds of makers messing around with
sapphire cases which are very expensive
and these guys are doing it at a very
affordable price point but also you know
when I wear that piece out it's a show
stopper you know it's it's really out
there and it actually wears quite nicely
it's a huge piece this looks like a race
car on the wrist it is quite frankly it
is a race car good analogy Teddy nailed
it right there lots of fun uh speak
Marin
so this is a cool independent brand that
interesting to see that you had this so
this is known as their fruity tuning yep
Fruity Tooty head pain Tutti Frutti
pardon me Tutti Frutti Frutti whatever
you want but it's it's it's the dial
that is so striking it looks like I
watched that would be named that correct
and also the case so this brand was
started by Peter uh speak correct who uh
started the Springer associated with
exactly no longer associated with the
brand uh but he started in 2000 uh in
early 2000s and he came out with a watch
called the Piccadilly yeah and that was
very much in aligned with this you had
like this cases hinged off lugs design
the other thing that I like about this
is you have this kind of copper looking
dial and then the kind of a skew sub
seconds that you have at that one
o'clock position that's that's out there
it's out there um there's only 10 of
these in the world this is the only one
with the red band obviously which is so
I propose is this the so they did a 38
and a 42 which one is this this is the
42. 42 yeah okay it's quite stunning but
this was purchased my collection as an
investment because when I get an
opportunity to buy one of ten of
anything I'm going to take it because
long term that's a very good outcome
usually so this brand is not as well
known as many others but is making some
extraordinary pieces and again my
measure last night I had dinner with my
daughter here in New York everybody that
came over the table said what is that
that's for me that's what a watch is all
about it starts the conversation this
piece starts a conversation so I love it
I'm wearing it today because it's a
beautiful piece but it's just another
collectible and by the way did get
headlined on Shark Tank because it was
on season 14 so it's going to have a
special place Teddy longine let's just
talk about that for a second huge fan of
long Jane in terms of the fifteen
hundred dollar to like four thousand
dollar price range among the best this
is their Heritage Classic sector with
the black dial they have one in silver
as well I own the silver you pick out
the black in our one episode yeah it's
just a sharp watch it's just remarkable
and also the sector does design there's
others that will do it it's this design
that's more defined by these concentric
circles that house the hour and the
Menace on the outside of the track they
do it better than anybody in the price
range classic and again Wardrobe from
Shark Tank fell in love with this piece
and it also showcased for the first time
on season 14. probably go into rotation
for season 15. it looks so great on
television and you're looking for those
dials this is so unique there's nothing
quite like it and it's got a lot of
interesting elements to it in terms of a
standout look clean symmetry look at the
cemetery Symmetry and an incredibly
affordable piece yeah and you're talking
about 2500 on the bracelet I mean if you
haven't looked a long jean and you're
just starting your journey into
collecting you there's so many
opportunities there for under five
thousand dollars that are fantastic
pieces this is one of one of my
favorites let's see what's left we
haven't talked about Hamilton in a while
Let's Do It um
this is a piece that is eight hundred
dollars that I bought in this store last
time we had a little sales contest
together here
it's become one of my favorites that's
great it looks so beautiful it's a
smaller dial also it's very safe to wear
in the sense when I'm in a metropolitan
area which is known these days in big
cities you have to be careful with your
watch absolutely I don't want to take
risks with you know 20 30 40 or 200 000
piece but I want to look great I always
have to look great and this is a
fantastic piece talk a little bit about
what Hamilton's been doing lately so
Hamilton's I know their history they
were a U.S brand until 1969 in Lancaster
Pennsylvania and what they were known
for primarily was their field watches
for the United States military and the
Allied Forces so during World War II
they came up with some amazing field
watches that were used in in battle and
they developed that reputation as pretty
much the standard for under a thousand
dollars what kind of quality are you
getting for 800 bucks there it's
incredible I mean honestly I think of
two Swiss brands that set the standard
for under a thousand bucks I think of
Hamilton I think of T cell if you like
the diet if you like the more field
watch design simply put Hamilton is the
best yeah Swiss made movement ADR power
Reserve also you're talking about a
bronze case here which usually most
bronze cases not going to find under a
thousand dollars unless you go for some
more out there micro Brands they're one
of the only mainstream brands that are
doing this but 825 for this watch it's
just incredible well listen I hope you
enjoyed this you know the whole idea of
working with Teddy on this is we're
going to the barbell approach as I like
to say I started my journey in watch
collecting at the very very high-end
investment grade watches and I was a
watch snob until I met Teddy I'm Stella
watch snob but I own a lot of entry
level pieces for One Singular reason the
dials are spectacular it shouldn't be
about what it costs it should be about
what it says and where it fits in your
collection that's what matters are you
buying something different are you
buying something special are you getting
a unique dial that you never had before
regardless of price one last point I
want you all to think about and I've
said this countless times never go into
debt to buy a watch never you buy what
you can afford and as you go through
your journey in life you can afford more
as you work your way through the key is
never to actually borrow money to buy a
watch many people think you don't need a
timepiece anymore because you have it on
your phone all the time if the phone's
with you
this is about collecting art this is
about supporting watchmakers Who start
their Journey at ages of 14 15. this is
about celebration of a unique class of
art watches I agree with that 100 the
only thing I would add to is watches is
one of those rare things where you can
Aspire your entire life you'll never
you're chasing something think about
where you're at in your career you're
still chasing that thing and the other
thing about just why watches are still
needed maybe they're not needed they're
Antiquated Goods but the thing that I
love about watches I think they're so
special we live in a world that's so
disposable everything just goes away
these things last a lifetime they become
a legacy in your family you know my son
Trevor he's licking his chops at all
these watches and I told him don't even
think about it they're all coming in my
coffin everything's going with me
because where I'm going I need a good
timepiece anyways thank you so much see
you next time